não resta mais dúvidas de que vivemos
uma realidade inédita totalmente
transformada pela tecnologia mas isso
também nos coloca diante de um grande
problema
esse problema é o fato de que as teclas
ciências elas avançaram de forma muito
mais rápida do que a nossa capacidade de
compreender as interpretá las e mediar é
de forma equilibrada e justa com suas
implicações
então é urgente sincronizar - nossa
concepção sobre a tecnologia a fim de
construir uma concepção mais adequada
que nos ajude a lidar com essa realidade
quem não fizer isso ou seja quem não
souber interpretar de forma adequada o
que está acontecendo muito provavelmente
já está sendo ou certamente será
atropelado
nas próximas na próxima década nos
próximos anos ou perder algo importante
no caminho um exemplo do descompasso da
nossa concepção de tecnologia em relação
à realidade já possa pelas teclas
ciências ou seja um atestado da nossa
inabilidade é exatamente formular de
forma precisa e lycra qual é exatamente
o problema por trás de algumas
tecnologias emergentes recentes
no caso das biotecnologias que é sem
dúvida uma uma das áreas mais polêmicas
nós não inventamos sem dúvida uma das
tecnologias mais incríveis já vistas na
unidade que se chama crisp é uma
tecnologia de edição genética ela em
breve nos permitir a editar nós dna ou
seja substituir algum e das alguns genes
que estão envolvidos no desenvolvimento
de algumas doenças e substituir por
genes saudáveis
é muito próprio e essa tecnologia já
está sendo aplicada em embriões humanos
é muito provável que os nossos filhos ou
netos
já tenho essa opção disponível mas nós
não temos muito problema em conceber
bebês sem genes envolvidos em doenças
como câncer como alzheimer
isso não parece ser um problema mas nós
temos claramente um mal-estar um
desconforto quando pensamos em bebês com
algumas é conceber bebês com algumas
qualidades selecionadas por exemplo
inteligência altura cor de olhos
este é claramente um problema mas onde
exatamente que está esse problema
quem é que consegue formular com clareza
qual é o problema o qual é a diferença
entre eliminarmos um gene responsável no
desenvolvimento de uma doença tão grave
tão sofrível como câncer ou alzheimer e
qual é o problema em conceber bebês com
qualidades selecionadas outra outra
questão difícil de responder é apenas
aparentemente fácil é identificar o
problema entre é no fato de a arábia
saudita ter sido o primeiro país a ter
conferido cidadania um robô
onde está o problema não é fácil
responder essas perguntas
então o fato interessante sobre a
tecnologia é que o avanço tecnológico
ele não é acompanhado de avanços moral
então nós vivemos uma espécie de
vertigem moral um mal estar uma
impressão desconfortável e persistente
de que alguém algo errado mas ninguém
ainda sabe muito bem exatamente o que é
então ao longo da minha pesquisa sobre
tecnologia
eu percebi que muito desse nosso mal
estar
esse nosso descompasso dessa nossa
unidade em lidar com essa realidade já
posta e inconstante complexificação das
teclas ciências é o fato de operarmos
com uma concepção da tecnologia defasada
incompatível e que não nos ajuda a dar
conta dessa realidade a idéia de
tecnologia que nós precisaremos revisar
e superar a ideia que a tecnologia como
um instrumento neutro a serviço de
quaisquer fins
nós escolhemos quaisquer objetivos
por exemplo se essa idéia e ela está
presente por trás de um raciocínio que
todos vocês conhecem muito bem
é o seguinte raciocínio armas não matam
pessoas pessoas matam pessoas armas são
apenas um instrumento que pode ser usado
tabu matar ou proteger
veja 1
esse raciocínio ele pressupõe que de um
lado existem dispositivos tecnológicos
por exemplo celular armas televisão e de
outro os nossos objetivos os nossos
valores
então desse lado nós usamos a arma ou
para proteger ou para atacar
usamos o smartphone ou para nos
comunicar
oprah nos distrair a televisão ela
também pode poderia ser usada tanto para
informar como para manipular essa
dissociação ela é equivocada e perigosa
porque ela nos impede ela nos afasta da
compreensão de algo essencial da
natureza da tecnologia que é o fato de
que a usarmos uma tecnologia
ela nos define profundamente e no caso
de uma tecnologia que se torne global é
redefinir a espécie humana ou seja
o seu impacto é muito maior do que um
instrumento que nós podemos desligar
quando a gente quiser é ou não usar
quando ele não funciona mais
ou começa a dar efeitos indesejados um
exemplo de como o uso de tecnologias
afeta a nossa capacidade de auto
percepção ea nossa auto consciência ea
forma como entendemos o percebemos a
realidade é o uso de redes sociais
quem é que tem uma rede social e mexe
nela com regularidade e quem de vocês já
se pegou pensando nas próprias
experiências nos eventos importantes da
sua vida é um livro que leram séries que
assistiram filmes que virão em viagens
que não nunca se pegou pensando nesses
eventos em forma de post de rede social
informa d&b de um formato né com um
formato com uma frase de efeito e uma
foto mas a fota meticulosamente criado
tirada por exemplo desse dessa questão
ou seja o quanto a tecnologia ela
incorpora escolhas valores de forma
intrínseca de forma profunda e ela nos
redefinir é o cinto de segurança
o cinto de segurança ele
ele foi projetado ele foi concebido na
sua origem com um valor com uma escolha
específica que é de proteger a vida
então quando nós criamos carros com
inovações do tipo o carro só vai andar
ou ele vai soar um alarme é só vai
deixar só um alarme quando o cinto foi
conectado ou quando o cinto ele se torna
objeto de política pública e e há uma
lei no
obriga a usar o cinto nós percebemos
claramente o quando na criação das
tecnologias é o próprio design e da
tecnologia expressa valores expressos
escolhas
isso significa que eu quero dizer que as
tecnologias na sua própria estrutura da
sua própria criação
elas privilegiam alguns aspectos da
experiência humana e excluem outros
por isso que elas nos redefinir de forma
profunda
isso significa que uma sociedade que
decide investir em carros e tecnologia
de carros ou em transporte público é uma
sociedade que tem escolhas diferentes
uma sociedade que é preciso investir
recursos em tecnologias de energia
verdes renováveis é diferente da escolha
de investir em tecnologia nuclear
essa compreensão ela nos permite
perceber o que está por trás de cada
tecnologia ou seja quais aspectos da
nossa identidade ela privilegia e quais
ela suprime e esse entendimento nos
capacita a nos posicionar de forma menos
passiva em jena em relação à tecnologia
nós vivemos em uma época muito especial
estamos colhendo os frutos mais maduros
da terceira revolução industrial que
começou na metade do século passado e
que é conhecida como revolução
informacional revolução tecnocientífica
ou revolução digital
essa revolução é caracterizada pela
onipresença das teclas cinzas na nossa
vida sobretudo pela integração radical
entre o mundo físico e digital a menos
que algo excepcional aconteça nós
prosseguiremos a nossa margem no
desenvolvimento dessas tecnologias
isso é um caminho incontornável
assim como é inevitável o fato de que
até o fim deste século o modo como
entendemos humanos será radicalmente
transformado a simbiose a parceria entre
homem máquina ela é permitida qualquer
proposta de abandonar a tecnologia ou se
apegar a uma ilusão de uma natureza
humana fixa e imutável ela fracassará
estamos caminhando na direção de uma
automação e conexão total
prova disso é o surgimento de
tecnologias como internet das coisas
dispositivos de realidade virtual
realidade ampliada ou mesmo a adesão
cada vez mais radical da população a
redes sociais ou aplicativo de conversa
porém aspectos da nossa experiência essa
tecnologia privilegia e quais ela super
ele claramente esses dispositivos
privilegiam muito mais
as interações virtuais do que as
concretas as sensíveis
eu me pergunto agora eu pergunto pra
vocês
se é isso que nós queremos se essa
renúncia sistemática da corporeidade não
significaria a perda de algo essencial
pelo caminho
vejam é inevitável que a vergonha que a
virtualidade ela esteja cada vez mais
presente na nossa vida é maravilhoso
você viajar e poder se comunicar
lá houve ver pessoas queridas que estão
longe
é maravilhoso é maravilhoso também
pensar em inteligências artificiais que
auxilie os médicos a um diagnóstico mais
preciso mais rápido
problemas no entanto me parece que não é
uma boa ideia prescindimos totalmente da
conexão real ao vivo em função de uma
conexão permanentemente virtual é
possível que resguardar momento para
conexão à moda antiga ou mais física
possível seja uma coisa que vale a pena
ser conservada
eu estou cada vez mais convencido de que
muito da nossa verdade muito da nossa
singularidade da nossa capacidade de nos
compreendemos profundamente se encontre
justamente na fragilidade e no caráter
muitas vezes desconcertante do corpo
pelo qual nós somos radicalmente
revelados
muito mais do que as identidades
flutuantes idealizados da rede
um dos grandes sonhos da inteligência
artificial é transferir a consciência
para a máquina
estaríamos assim liberta de todas as
limitações biológicas e em última
instância da própria finitude
deveríamos infinitamente como pura
informação no cyber espaço
mas se pensarmos bem ele a imperfeição
ea plenitude
talvez sejam justamente o que dá sentido
a experiência humana enquanto nos
compreendemos como seres desejantes de
ser de ação
a perfeição ela mata o desejo o que
resta desejar quando temos a perfeição
assim como a infinitude a eternidade ela
matar são quem é que se levantar do sofá
para fazer alguma coisa
se vivemos eternamente haveria ainda
algum sonho pra sonhar se fossemos
perfeitos
obrigado